NARRATOR: Scientists
in far North Australia
have made a startling
new discovery that
has to be seen to be believed.
At just 9 million years old, the
epaulette shark is the youngest
shark species on the planet.
And look what it can do.
It has thick, round
muscular fins that it
can bend and use like legs.
And now this shark takes this
behavior one step further--
make that many steps.
The largest epaulette
shark is 3 feet long.
It's a hardy animal that
can tolerate water so hot it
would kill any other fish.
On land, it slows its
breathing and heart rate
allowing it to survive
for an hour or even longer
without any water at all.
The epaulette shark may be
different from a great white
or a bull shark, but it's
evidence of evolution.
Just like whales were
once land animals that
returned to the ocean,
sharks may evolve
one day to come on to land.